بالتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الثالثه
لاغتيال القائد في الحرس الثوري قاسم
سليمان اللي اسمه تراند على تويتر من
امبارح والسبب ليست ذكرى السنويه ابدا
السبب حمل قاده جيوش الالكترونيه لميليشيا
ايران واعلام النظام الايراني بهدف
الترويج لمعلومات انه قاسم سليماني هو
اللي يحرر العراق من تنظيم داعش الارهاب
ومجرد ما انتشر الاخبار كان الرد عليهم من
الناس العراقيين انفسهم بهاشتاجيت تصدرت
العناوين في تويتر وهي تحت رسم لا منا
لاحد على العراق ولا العراق سيد نفسه
وتحول لقب البطل اللي حاولت وسائل الاعلام
النظام الايراني نشره واطلاقه على سليمان
الى لقب القاتل والارهاب لاطلقوا عليه
المغردين العراقيين وتصدر تويتر رسوم
كاريكاتير وهاشتاجات بتلخص كل الجدل اللي
صاير حول الموضوع
[موسيقى]